look at me I care about you  I want you to succeed but at what cost  they're gonna crash oh what he's not  even looking at the road at all I can't  spoil it for you you're not gonna every  day I wake up and cry because they're  they're you are are being bad there's  gonna be a car accident he's driving  normally I've seen movies I know how  movies work I don't know I just think  you're screwing up look he just looked  at the road he's driving I know how  driving works that's not that's not how  it works maybe it's a Tesla this came  out in 2003. it's fine it's not a big  deal looks like we're at our destination  oh what did I say huh all right does  anyone smell gas like a gas leak does  anyone does it seem like there's a gas  leak all right